hey man it's me kevin smith here to do a
scene study from mall rats and we're
gonna look at the schooners not a
sailboat scene man the ethan
scene willem black himself played by
ethan cepley who does
not look like this character anymore man
go look at lethal now
he's [ __ ] jacked we'll drop a picture
in it
look out jack that is it looks like
willem's
dad like hard ass [ __ ] dad and [ __ ]
like that
um so back in the day uh ethan
uh took the part of willem black
from scott mosier scott mosher was
originally intended to play this
character maratz as he played the
character of willem black
in clerks same guy that sits there and
talks to veronica and dante about 37
um you know snowball his name was will
and black
so scott was going to play will and
black and mall rats until ethan came in
to audition
and ethan was like i don't want to
audition for anything else except
willem black you know me and scott look
at each other like this [ __ ] kid
the ball's on this [ __ ] kid taking
scotty's part trying to get scotty's
part
we'll listen to him and he was so
[ __ ] good that afterwards i was like
i don't know scott
like maybe we should do it scott's like
you know what
it's not my part like feel free and so
the willem of two worlds theory was born
in clerks willem looks like scott willem
black and mall rats will in black looks
like
uh ethan or it looked like ethan's plea
looked back in 1995 for heaven six
so uh also uh one of the only things
that you know there's a lack of cell
phones in this movie and [ __ ]
but one of the things that really
[ __ ] nails it in a period of time
are those magic eye posters they were
[ __ ] huge
at the moment that we made that movie so
that's why you know and particularly in
malls anytime you went to a mall you're
like another [ __ ] magic eye kiosk
so that's how it winds up in mall rats
and stuff and to be honest with you
uh if you've you know now people have
perfect paws and [ __ ] blu-rays and
[ __ ] like that you'd probably be able to
do it right here
if you pause it and stare at the magic
eye poster
you will not ever see a sailboat
it's not a sailboat it's a series of
geometric shapes like a
circle a square and triangle and i'll
never forget prop master brian
telling me like uh i was like is it a
sailboat and he goes
nah i couldn't find a sailboat he's gone
it's just some shapes
and i was like well it's not like
anybody's gonna be able to [ __ ] see
it anyway all right let's go for it and
[ __ ]
and then years later with the advent of
the internet i get hit with a lot of
people at least once a month somebody on
social media is like
that ain't a [ __ ] sailboat you lying
piece of [ __ ]
just some shapes so check it out for
yourself man
just some shapes or a sailboat just some
shapes uh
enjoy this amazing performance uh by
ethan sipley
uh as well as jason lee playing brody
bruce
and uh of course um ts
uh who was played by uh jeremy london
so mall rats the willem black scene
willam
[Music]
willam brody man
what's going on why do you work here now
oh man just hanging with t.s
oh it's yes willem what exactly are you
doing
looking for the hidden picture if you
stare at these things long enough you're
supposed to see some kind of hidden
three-dimensional picture
oh yeah look it's a sailboat you saw it
too
damn it what i've been staring at this
thing for a week now from opening till
closing and i can't see a goddamn thing
you gotta relax your eyes everyone sees
this thing except me
today's my day brought a lunch and a
soda and i'm not gonna leave until i see
the sailboat everyone keeps talking
about hey kids did you like that
all these movies are available on itunes
or netflix in some places
amazon and other places you can find
them they're available
patronize them if you will uh also if
you like this kind of stuff come on over
to that kevin smith club
go to thatkevinsmithclub.com join up man
i do wake and bake three times a week
where i wake up just smoke weed with you
all and stuff come to that kevin smith
club for more
video antics with kevin smith